[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je travaille à la diction
valait une fondation qui a pour but de
soutenir les personnes qui développent
une consommation excessive ou une
dépendance à l'alcool aux drogues aux
médicaments ou qui ont un usage excessif
des écrans des jeux vidéo des jeux
d'argent en fait à tout ce qui peut
devenir une dépendance et donc provoquer
une perte de liberté un jeune homme de
20 ans que j'accompagne depuis quatre
ans d'entretien ambulatoire a accepté de
témoigner pour vous aujourd'hui via un
audio sa vie d'adolescents et de jeunes
adultes a été parsemée de difficultés
d'obstacles à affronter et son
témoignage est la preuve que oui la
consommation est une perte totale de
liberté mais qu'il est possible de
trouver le chemin de la guérison
comment définis-tu le début de ta
consommation en lien avec la liberté de
constater les produits
alors
quand j'ai commencé c'était déjà dans
une période où j'ai rien au mal-être
j'étais vraiment pas bien j'étais comme
prisonnier de mes mauvaises émotions et
mon premier jeu en fait ça a été comme
ça moi c'était très mal c'était
l'anniversaire du décès de mon père est
un type m'a vu dans ce ballet mallié
tiens j'ai quelque chose pour toi et
j'ai fumé deux joints j'ai des gens
tellement horreur que j'ai oublié toute
ma tristesse et voilà c'était mon
premier juin j'ai été d'ailleurs été
demandée trois heures d'un nouveau
médicament mais ça c'est vraiment été la
première fois ça marc donet légende le
sourire ça ça m'a fait connaître un peu
un bonheur 29 factice
donc en fait une certaine forme de
liberté
j'avais aussi des parents qui était le
protecteur est à cheval sur la bonne
éducation les bonnes manières espère
donc j'avais quand même un peu envie de
me rebeller
en plus c'était illégal donc
quand on est jeune on est vraiment
attiré parce qu'on n'a pas le droit de
faire désobéir aux parents et c'est
vraiment là que tu commences à me sentir
vivre en paix
l'adolescence c'est un temps où chacun
devient de plus en plus autonome où
chacun fait des choix pour son avenir ou
passer du temps avec ses amis prend tout
son sens mais là de l'essence comme on
l'a entendu c'est aussi une période de
doutes de rebellions de questionnements
et de prise de risque comme par exemple
la consommation de drogues consommées ça
peut être vu comme le moyen de se
libérer de toutes ces règles de tout
c'est autour de ces autorités mais cela
peut rapidement déraper et devenir une
vraie prison
quels ont été les signes qui ont montré
que tu perds mais petit à petit la
liberté de choisir de consommer non ces
substances
alors bon déjà j'ai eu plusieurs prises
de conscience mais il ya un
type un peu comme le diable qui
s'appelle le déni qui reprenait sans
cesse de dessus
c'est à dire ah mais est ce que c'est
vraiment bien de fumée le quatrième juin
là ce soir
ouais c'est pas grave j'ai pas de
problème sera très bien de façon
j'arrive demain si je veux et voilà du
coup je retombais dans ce déni dans ça
va c'est pas si grave que ça et c'est
très vite j'ai commencé à voler pour
devoir payer les consommations que
j'avais
j'avais dans le contenu et de ma mère au
début ça a commencé par cinq francs dit
franck très vite ça a été 100 200 francs
parce que j'ai commencé avec de l'aveu
la beuh qui n'est pas si cher que ça
quand on en prend à usage récréatif mais
ensuite ça suffisait plus donc j'ai dû
aller plus fort à savoir le chiffre est
à peu près le même et clappent
qu'ensuite c'est tombé beaucoup plus
loin genre ecstasy cocaïne amphétamines
comme s'il y avait toujours besoin de
plus parce qu au grand jour le corps il
va s'habituer à ce qu'on lui donne il va
avoir besoin de plus pour goûter en fait
au bonheur qu'on lui a fait connaître
avant du coup c'est pour ça que j'ai
toujours eu besoin de dreux plus forte
et du coup le prix augmenter beaucoup
avec pour donner une petite idée avec 20
franc je vous aime faire 3 4 juin plus
tard avec 20 franc je me faisais une
pilule d'ecstasy donc il y avait
toujours besoin de plus d'argent
au bout d'un moment j'ai même aussi
commencé à refuser par des gens pour
être tout seul consommer donc je me suis
enfermé moi même et je me suis enlevé
cette liberté moi même parce que mes
potes m'appeler wes a dit de sortir on
va boire un verre machin et moi en fait
c'est juste qu'on le laisse tranquille
et qu'on me tue mais qu'on laisse tirer
mon ami tranquille et du coup je restais
chez moi à ne rien faire à m'éclater de
la tête et c'était devenu très toxiques
parce que je voyais plus mes potes j'en
ai perdu beaucoup à cause de ça on ne
voit plus tu sors plus qu'est-ce qui se
passe et puis moi pas du coup je te pète
un peu les plans contre eux passent en
savage droit d'être seul du coup pas y
partagent les voiliers plus
j'ai commencé à habiter deux seuls
d'abord j'étais en foyer puis quand tu
t'appelles foyer j'ai habité seul dans
mon appartement je ne rentrais plus chez
moi parce que je voulais rester les
week-ends
enfermée chez moi à consommer je voyais
plus beaucoup mes parents ou alors je
les voyais de samedi de trois heures et
même d'être avec eux je n'étais pas
vraiment avec eux parce que dans ma tête
c'était aller dans 2 hearts et de
retouche et toi tu tu enfiles un énorme
besoin allez dans une halle 45t je suis
pas allé dans une heure et demie aller
dans une attaque est en fait certains
disent que non je partais et
c'était pas ça ne profitait pas de ma
famille n'était pas là avec eux quand je
devais l'être et tout ça ça s'est fini
par une overdose
ça c'est aussi un grand danger c'est
qu'on sait jamais vraiment avec
certitude qu'on achète moi je pensais
acheter tel produit et au final je me
suis retrouvé avec un sachet qui en
avait trois autres en plus de ce produit
là et j'ai commencé à tirer ça comme si
c'était le produit de base et
en fait j'ai fait une overdose je me
suis retrouvé très mal
j'ai pas je crois pas fait d'arrêt
cardiaque qui mais il ya quand même
cette possibilité parce que j'ai un gros
trou noir
entre le moment où j'ai quitté l'endroit
où va retrouver et moment je suis
arrivée à l'hôpital
j'ai fait j'ai eu des grosses
complications au niveau psychologique
pendant pendant quelques semaines à
l'hôpital de volley-ball hôpital
psychatrique un contest j'ai été soigné
pour vers schizophrénie je prenais des
doses de cheval malgré sage parler aux
morts je parlais au mur je voyais des
gens personne d'autre wyeth c'était
vraiment un cauchemar pour revenir à la
liberté bas j'ai été emprisonné en enfer
pour moi je l' ai vécu comme ça
c'est là que j'ai commencé à perdre pied
maintenant j'ai commencé à papier avant
et le pathos et là je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais perdu pied voilà les
gens consomment des drogues pour se
calmer ou pour se détendre ou parfois au
contraire pour se donner de l'énergie ou
alors pour oublier durant quelques
minutes les soucis quotidiens
mais pour ressentir toujours le même
effet le corps réclame toujours de plus
en plus de quantité de substance et
rapidement on est plus libre de choisir
si l'on veut consommer ou non mais cela
devient un besoin une priorité une
priorité qui passe avant tout quitte à
perdre ses amis à s'isoler de sa famille
être dépendant ça veut dire continuer à
consommer malgré les conséquences
négatives
on est donc plus libres de nos choix se
rendent compte de cet engrenage n'est
pas facile mais cela est nécessaire pour
pouvoir ensuite mettre en place des
solutions pour s'en sortir
comment as tu fait pour t'en sortir
retrouvez cette liberté
alors on peut dire que la liberté elle a
commencé en privons
gérer une cure de désintoxication
que j'ai très mal vécu au début à savoir
j'avais pas mon téléphone
mais si jamais j'ai partant donc pour
moi par téléphone c'est comme pour vous
ne pas avoir de téléphone savage pas
mais tu pourrais y avait pas de
téléphone j'avais pas la possibilité de
de téléphoner à mes parents que vos
premiers mois j'ai pas de possibilité de
visite pendant premiers mois est
vraiment mauvais jusqu'au jour où je me
suis rendu compte que j'étais là pour
moi
et que je me suis dit que vraiment il
fallait que je fasse ce chemin doit m'en
sortir et c'est là que petit à petit je
voyais cette fenêtre au bout de cette
salle noire je voyais ce n'est
la suite de ma cure s'est bien passé je
suis ressorti et
très vite j'ai rechuté parce que gros
malin que je suis j'ai vu que ça faisait
six mois que je n'avais plus touchés de
joints et pour cela je me suis dit allez
on va fêter ça fume un joint
et très vite je suis retombé et très
vite c'est bien s'est monté très vite ça
pas été au port le lent que la première
fois j'ai réussi à ne pas consommer de
drogues dures sur la durée j'ai eu une
rechute avec un extasié mais ç'a
vraiment été la tâche c'est mon problème
à ce moment-là que j'ai très vite
su renverser la balance parce que j'en
ai parlé il était un petit groupe pro
tour - j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle une
bonne cure à la villa flora
en tant que centre de jour et la
servante ici pour coup et était parce
que je j'étais en année n il est
apathique parce que je ne sentais pas
prêt à reprendre quelque chose alors que
je venais de sortir de thérapie et
surtout cet organisme avait beaucoup
altéré mais les capacités cognitives
j'avais plus mémoire des fois je vais
chercher mes phases pendant un bon
moment j'ai été très touchée tout ça
ce sont des choses qui sont en train de
reprendre maintenant très bien ma
mémoire s'améliore
mais du coup c'est cette posture maïder
ma palette de transition entre eux ça va
pas bien du tout j'ai pu mémoire je sais
plus ce que je fais machin est à
maintenant
au moins d'août je commence
un stage donc éducateurs pour enfants en
situation de handicap c'est
mon travail de rêve j'ai toujours voulu
faire ça j'ai toujours voulu être là
pour mon prochain être surtout les
appréciations de mon handicap ayant un
frère on est en situation de handicap
j'ai toujours voulu me dire mais je me
dis que faire cette veine j'ai envie
d'aider les gens j'ai envie d'être là
pour je sais que je peux leur apporter
quelque chose avec mon vécu et c'est
la liberté maintenant bas
je suis libre des chaînes et seychelles
en fait c'était la consommation j'ai
vraiment réussi à briser sa et
ouais je suis libre aussi dans la soupe
dans le sens que j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance
j'ai jamais eu de problèmes avec la
justice j'ai toujours réussi à
contourner le truc j'ai été souvent
contrôlés par la police mais à partir
d'un moment quand tu es là dedans tu
sais que
à partir de tangram dal droit dans
l'avoir surpoids à partir de temps tu as
plus droit donc je m'arrangeais toujours
pour sortir avec genre juste la nuit et
j'ai toujours réussi hier à
filer entre les gouttes comme ça ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui j'ai un casier
judiciaire qui est vierge et on retrouve
cette liberté cette liberté de faire ce
que je veux de ma vie je peux être
éducateur derrière combat être éducateur
nous demande un extrait de casier
judiciaire et moi je suis tellement
content tellement rassuré pouvoir tendre
une feuille où c'est écrit que je ne
figure pas au casier judiciaire
voilà
sans sortir des consommations n'est pas
de tout repos cela demande beaucoup de
travail de temps d'introspection de
motivation de persévérance il est
possible de mettre fin aux consommations
mais comme nous l'avons entendu la
rechute reste toujours un risque bien
présent mais comme nous dit socrate la
chute n'est pas un échec l'échec c'est
de rester là où nous sommes tombés en
effet personne n'est responsable de
tomber dans la dépendance de rechuter
mais par contre chacun un responsable de
se soigner de mettre en place des
alternatives à la consommation de
retrouver des plaisirs plus sain afin de
retrouver sa liberté
comment est ce que tu pourrais définir
la liberté aujourd'hui
comme un labyrinthe
avec au milieu
des petits des petits trucs dont m'aider
à avancer
moi j'en ai j'en ai plus violents donc
je suis rentré dans ce labyrinthe très
tôt
sort que j'ai j'ai pas gâcher ma
jeunesse que j'ai pas une jeunesse comme
tout le monde aurait pu en avoir je suis
rentré très peu dans ce labyrinthe et
1 un des premiers trucs que j'ai pu
prendre m d'en bas dans mon sac est pour
m'aider à avancer c'est la fois je suis
très croyant en dieu m'a beaucoup aidé
dans ce cas dans mon chemin
ensuite un peu plus loin j'ai trouvé la
musique
chose qui m'a de nouveau donné beaucoup
de confiance en moi on savait pas je
chantais j'écoutais je composais je
jouais et
oui c'est selon les deux choses
principales api théâtre aussi qui m'a
aidé à faire tomber le masque que je me
mettais et oui tout va bien tout va bien
alors que derrière ce masque non ça
n'avait pas du tout
et ça ça a été le la période d'avant
maintenant je suis toujours dans cette
année entre parce que je sais que
l'archipel
elle est là quelque part elle m'attend
quelques pas donc je vais me retrouver
dans un cul de sac mais je dois faire
marche arrière et avancer plus loin dans
la terreur pour au final trouver la
sortie
sous forme de deux
deux devis poser une vie de famille un
travail stable et le des enfants des
amis qui ont été la halle avec moi
pendant des dizaines d'années et
voilà comment je vois la fin de la
liberté comment je vois actuellement ma
liberté c'est vraiment un allié je suis
j'en suis pas encore sorti ça va être un
travail qui va des années et des années
mais je sais que je dois sortir par
moment donné
voilà le témoignage de ce jeune qui est
une histoire de vie parmi plein d'autres
que je rencontre tous les jours dans mon
travail il faut savoir bien sûr que
chaque situation chaque parcours de vie
est unique et différent et chacun
développe ses propres moyens pour
pouvoir s'en sortir et retrouver sa
liberté
merci pour votre écoute et bonne suite
de soirée
[Applaudissements]